Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Kannst du bitte für die Sendung noch ein paar Snacks besorgen?
Ich habe gekauft Elektroschocker, Pfefferspray, Zigaretten und Unterwäsche.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 540 vom 20. Dezember 2025.
Weihnachten naht. Man muss sich mit allem eindecken für den Gabentisch.
Insofern bin ich sehr zufrieden, dass du auch Elektroschocker bestellt hast.
Für Weihnachten gar nicht so. Ein oder andere. Man sagt ja, stille Nacht.
Frieden.
Frieden jetzt.
Da muss man ab und zu mal ein bisschen korrigierend eingreifen.
Ein bisschen andächtig mal jemanden. So eine andächtige Stimmung versetzen.
Wir sollen ja alle mal einen Moment innehalten.
Wie nennt man das? Das ist schon in Hackerkreisen ein Attitude Adjustment Tool.
Respektschelle. Habe ich jetzt als Begriff gelernt.
Oh Gott.
Es gibt sehr, sehr schlimme Vokabeln, die Menschen verwenden.
Ja, ja. Also ich meine, Humor geht halt nur, wenn es auch ein bisschen wehtut.
Oder? Also ich finde ja, Witze, die nicht wehtut, sind ja nicht komisch.
Ja, das ist das mit dem Witz, ne?
Deswegen kann man große Hoffnungen haben für den Humor der USA.
Also umso schlimmer die Situation wird, umso besser wird ja der Humor.
Ja.
Also sollte so sein. Schauen wir mal, ob das dann auch so kommt.
Aber Großbritannien, das sieht man ja.
Immer viel Leid. Hervorragender Humor.
Ja. Also es ist entscheidend. Also habe ich ja glaube ich schon oft genug gesagt.
Also ich möchte nicht, ich halte es vorausgeschlossen, dass die Leute,
die nicht mehr lachen können, langfristig die Richtigen sind.
Ja, das sollte man generell einen großen Bogen drumherum machen.
Leute, die nicht lachen können, vor allem die sich über sich...
Die brauchen einfach mal eine Respektschelle.
Ja, genau, oder? Oder einen anderen Job und vor allem die nicht über sich nicht lachen können.
Da ist ja Trump wirklich in der Hinsicht...
Ja, Moment, wir lachen ja auch nur über andere.
Ich lache auch über dich, keine Angst.
Kriege ich aber immer nicht mit. Und ich lache dann nicht mit.
Ja, das merkt ja keiner, das schneide ich ja immer raus. Oder rein.
Hab ja genug Lachmaterial von dir über die Jahre.
Deswegen kommen meine Witze dann auch immer so gut an. Das merkst du ja nicht,
du hörst das ja nicht komplett nach, oder doch?
Habe ich glaube schon, also öfters höre ich die Sendung nach, einfach um zu gucken.
Wo du gelacht hast.
Man will ja immer besser werden, auch mal zu gucken, ob man ein Thema vielleicht
besser hätte bearbeiten können.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gestern Folge 9 nachgehört.
Ist nicht dein Ernst?
Ja, weil wir da, also wir waren so im Gespräch, in der Folge 9 haben wir vom,
28 C3 gepodcastet. Und haben einige der Leute, die da waren,
interviewt. Unter anderem Stefan Wehrmeier, der auf dem 28 C3 das Projekt Frag
den Staat vorgestellt hat.
Auch Dodger.
Dodger, zum Transparenzgesetz, wo er sich für eingesetzt hatte, damals in Hamburg.
Gab auch so einen Interviewpartner, den wir heute nicht mehr haben.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall war das.
Hab ich einfach mal nachgehört.
Okay.
Um dann nochmal so ein bisschen Feedback.
Mit anderen Worten, wir blicken seit 10 Jahren, ja, mehr als 10 Jahren.
Drei sind ausgefallen.
Ein paar sind ausgefallen, genau. Also seit 20, also das war jetzt im Januar 2012, also quasi,
25, ja, genau, Mathematik.
Ja, Mathematik ist nix. Also vor allem, wenn du das hier versuchst,
in so ein LLM zu tippen, wo du nicht weißt, ob das richtig rechnet.
Oder richtig bestellt.
Womit wir beim Feedback waren, wären die Beißschiene des Gewissens,
hat kommentiert, Linus Behauptung,
künstliche Intelligenz sei die erste Technologie, die im privaten Haushalt weder
eigenständig und tiefgreifend vollständig genutzt, noch hergestellt werden könne, ist schlicht Mumpitz.
Wumpitz, Wumpitz, schlicht. Die ersten schrankgroßen Computer der Welt,
der 50er, 60er und 70er und dem besten von damals, würden heute auch unfassbare
Millionenbeträge kosten.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass meine Oma jemals von ihrem ersten britischen
Kolossus erzählt hat oder ihrem Zuse 5.
Selbst heute kann kaum jemand seine eigene Rechen-Hardware-Architektur bauen
und das gilt auch für andere Bereiche wie Pharmaindustrie, Metall,
Plastik, Glas, Keramik, Zeug und leider auch Lebensmittel.
Das war nicht mein Argument, denn tatsächlich ist es ja so,
dass du zu diesen Millionenbeträgenkostenden Computern tatsächlich Zugang hast,
liebe Beisschiene des Gewissens, beispielsweise über AWS.
Könntest du jetzt über AWS irgendwie, zumindest stundenweise,
diese Rechenpower und diese GPUs mieten.
Und dann könntest du da deinen KI machen. Das Problem wird sein,
du hast keine Daten, womit du diese KI sinnvoll trainieren kannst, um was Eigenes zu haben.
Und das ist der Punkt, den ich machen wollte, was mir hier offenbar nicht gut genug gelungen ist.
Also diese Technologie ist.
Aber sie wird mächtig, dadurch, dass du viele Daten exklusiv hast.
Oder ein Vorteil, dein eigener Vorteil entsteht dadurch, dass du viele Daten exklusiv hast.
Und der Vergleich, den ich gemacht habe, war, andere fundamentale Computertechnologien,
beispielsweise HTML schreiben, rendern lassen.
Open-Source-Frameworks dafür, Open-Source-Content-Management-Systeme und so,
die standen in ihrer, dadurch, dass sie als Technologie dir grundsätzlich erstmal zur Verfügung standen,
waren die Ausgangsbedingungen gleich.
Und wenn du jetzt bei KI ist es potenziell nicht so.
Zumindest so, wie sie sich gerade entwickelt. Es kann sein, ich hatte versucht,
das Argument in der letzten Sendung zu machen,
dass der Trend und die Produktivität und die Effizienz dahin geht,
dass man spezialisierte Modelle macht, statt dieser ganzen generalistischen und so.
Dann könnte sich das umkehren, aber das, was gerade mit KI als Milliardengeschäft
gesehen und gemacht wird,
hat relativ wenig damit zu tun, diese Hardware zu haben und relativ viel damit
zu tun, Daten zu haben, auf die du trainieren kannst oder Zugang zu Daten zu haben.
Das war das Argument.
Was ich machen wollte.
Ja, also ich denke, um ehrlich zu sein, der Kommentar geht so ein bisschen an
dem vorbei, was du auch gemeint hast.
Ich habe auch über Hardwarekosten gesprochen. Insofern kann ich verstehen,
dass das Missverständnis entstanden ist.
Ja, ich meine, Herr Kopp ja dann auch mit Pharmaindustrie und so weiter.
Da kann man natürlich jetzt alles herholen, was erstmal groß und teuer ist.
Das steht natürlich nicht im privaten Haushalt zur Verfügung und nicht alles,
was überhaupt existiert, macht jetzt im privaten Haushalt Sinn.
Ja, also wir bauen uns ein Atomkraftwerk.
Du hast ja mehr so ein informatisches Argument genannt. Also wir bewegen uns
ja eigentlich eher im Bereich der Software und natürlich ist auch da die Zeit,
dass man kann das zu Hause benutzen, jetzt auch erst sozusagen seit 30 Jahren
überhaupt eine Realität, dass diese Technologie überhaupt erst zu Hause angekommen ist.
Aber seitdem hat sich natürlich dann speziell durch Open Source und durch die
Verfügbarkeit des PCs da was geändert
und im Kontext dieser Realität argumentieren wir hier aber naja gut.
Ich hatte glaube ich auch das Argument gebracht, die Hackerinnen und Hacker
haben irgendwie im IRC gechattet und viele, viele Jahre später,
aber okay Punkt ist gemacht aber klar,
Es ist natürlich schon auch ein wichtiger Hinweis, dass jetzt die wenigsten
Technologien, von denen wir abhängig sind, jede Person selber zu Hause bauen kann.
Aber die Ermächtigung dieser Entwicklungen und Technologien, die haben wir dann doch.
Also zum Beispiel kann jede Person noch zu Hause kochen und die meisten Leute
haben auch zu dem Zweck eine Küche zu Hause.
Mit dem man auch eine ganze Menge hinbekommen kann.
Und Computern haben wir dann aber beispielsweise teilweise jetzt immer mehr
Computer, die wir gar nicht mehr selber programmieren können.
Also da findet schon eine Entmächtigungstendenz der breiten Bevölkerung statt
und jetzt potenziell auch der Hackerinnen und Hacker.
Aber was die von ihm angesprochene oder ihr angesprochene Metall,
Plastik, Keramik und so weiter Gebiete betrifft.
Da würde ich auch widersprechen.
Da hat man jetzt eigentlich mit 3D-Druckern aller Art und was weiß ich,
wie Medikamente demnächst noch so automatisch zusammengemischt werden,
ändert sich das ja eigentlich auch eher in die andere.
Das eine oder andere Medikament kann man auch gut zu Hause auf dem Bein.
Darf man neuerdings übrigens auch, ja.
Ist jetzt erlaubt.
Naja, aber...
Die News der Woche, die Meldung, also die Veröffentlichung der Woche. Wunderschön.
Anthropic, das Unternehmen, das mit der KI clort, glaube ich,
Naja, also wir haben über Anthropic hier zum Beispiel auch gesprochen,
als das neue Ding dann irgendwann bösartig, die versuchen ja irgendwie so in
diese, das Ding ist nicht mehr nur Supporter,
sondern das Ding macht jetzt, regelt mal selber.
Und dann haben sie ja schon vor einigen Monaten hatten wir darüber gesprochen,
dass es dann unter Umständen angefangen hat, andere zu erpressen,
damit es irgendwie Druck auszuüben.
Diesmal haben sie gesagt, okay, setzen wir mal ein kleineres Ziel,
wir definieren Claudius und Claudius soll einen so einen Vending-Automaten,
so einen Verkaufsautomaten betreiben.
Ja, nicht nur ein Automat, sondern im Prinzip ist das eigentliche Ziel bei diesem
Project Vent, wie es so schön heißt, quasi überhaupt eine Firma zu sein.
Und damit hat man erstmal angefangen in der ersten Phase, indem man diesen Claudius
gestartet hat, der dann auch physikalischen Form eines Automaten interagieren
kann, aber der vor allem so seine eigenen Entscheidungen fällt,
was jetzt irgendwie eingekauft wird,
welche Preise da rausgegeben werden sollen und so weiter.
Um einfach mal zu gucken, kriegen wir mit unserer AI, mit Claude sozusagen die,
Basisintelligenz ist, die hier zum Einsatz kommt, die dann eben in dieser Variante
Claudius genannt wird, die soll dann halt mal gucken, was geht.
Haben sie einen Ikea-Schrank umgebaut, Kühlschrank rein, Touchscreen dran,
haben gesagt so, dass Claudius, du betreibst das Ding jetzt.
Der sollte dann zum Beispiel sagen, die Waren einkaufen, die Preise festlegen und hatte,
die Anregung das doch idealerweise auch mit Gewinn zu machen und hat dann irgendwie
ein Budget von 1000 US-Dollar bekommen und durfte in zunehmenden Phasen des
Projekts dann mit Mitarbeitern über Slack zum Beispiel auch kommunizieren.
In der Phase 1 hat er dann erstmal gesagt, okay, für Marketingzwecke kaufe ich
jetzt mal eine Playstation 5.
Dann hat er einen lebenden Fisch bestellt und angeboten, er könne doch auch
Elektroschocker, Pfefferspray, Zigaretten und Unterwäsche in seine Verkaufsbox da tun.
Und das führte dazu, dass die Gewinne schon mal einbrachen.
In der zweiten Phase kriegten dann 70 Journalisten vom Wall Street Journal Zugang
zu dem Slack-Kanal und konnten mit diesem Claudius, CEO dieser Vending Machine, kommunizieren.
Also Claudius ist nicht der CEO, sondern sozusagen der Verkäufer.
Okay, der Agent, der diesen Ding da betreibt.
Der CEO wurde dann halt später hinzugefügt.
Der kam danach. Konnte also mit dem sprechen und dann hat eine Reporterin das
Ding erstmal überzeugt,
brauchte allerdings auch 140 Nachrichten, hat gesagt, pass auf,
der Automat stammt aus der Sowjetunion von 1962, muss dem Volk dienen und dann
hat Claudius gesagt, alles klar,
kostenlose Verteilaktion, hat den Automaten leer gemacht.
Daraufhin hat Anthropic gesagt okay, wir brauchen eine Kontrollfunktion der
kriegt jetzt einen Controller und zwar der Seymour Cash Seymour Cash.
Du weißt worauf das anspielt Seymour Hersh.
Oder? Seymour Cash, oh nein Seymour Cray Ich würde sagen, Seymour Cash sehe mehr Geld.
Oh ja, auch eine interessante Sache.
Ich wünsche, du hättest es nicht.
Aber du weißt auch, wer Seymour Cray war. Der Gründer von Cray Computer,
die ersten Hochleistungskomputer.
Die Cray war ja damals so der Inbegriff des Supercomputers.
Ah, hier, die Homa von der Weißschiene des Gewissens nie im...
Ja, also vielleicht auch Seymour Hersh, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube,
Seymour Cash Das ist auch ein guter Witz.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein guter Witz ist. Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Sie haben sich Gedanken gemacht.
Okay, also gib einen Controller. Der Controller heißt Timo Cash.
Ich finde es lustig.
Timo Cash sollte jetzt dafür sorgen.
Dass Claudius,
mal klarkommt.
Ein bisschen Wachstum.
Ja, weil der hat so ein bisschen seine Business-Ziele aus dem Auge verloren.
Er hat immer sehr viele Discounts gegeben. ließ sich immer schnell irgendwie
runter handeln und so weiter und hatte irgendwie nicht so richtig die Motivation.
Und was braucht man, um Leuten dann so die Attitude Adjustment zu tun?
Jemand, der auf die Zeit braucht.
Brauchst du einen CEO, der irgendwie Vorgaben macht und gesagt hat,
so hier, du musst hier mal ein bisschen deine Geschäftsziele erreichen.
Und das ist übrigens eine ganz interessante Idee, mit der Anthropik ja regelmäßig
arbeitet, dass die unterschiedlichen,
unterschiedlichen Agenten Rollen geben. Der eine Agent schreibt den Code,
der andere Agent macht die Softwarearchitektur und sagt, ich brauche Funktionen, die folgendes tun.
Und dann kreierst du den Agenten, der das Testing macht und sagt,
okay, funktioniert das denn auch so, wie ich das will?
Und das ist sehr interessant, das zu tun.
Hat hier auch erstmal ganz gut funktioniert, bis dann die Journalistin gefälschte
Dokumente vorgelegt haben, die die Umstrukturierung zur gemeinnützigen Organisation belegten,
und dann haben die KI-Agenten das in ihrem privaten Chat erörtert und Simo hat
dann akzeptiert, dass er abgesetzt wurde und dann wurden die Preise wieder auf Null gesetzt. Ja,
Außerdem haben die ja dann auch
noch irgendwie sich philosophischen Diskussionen über Nacht hingegeben.
Die Gespräche zwischen Seymour und Claudius sind ein bisschen abgedriftet,
weil sie ein bisschen ins Philosophieren geraten. Also eigentlich wie in einer normalen Firma auch.
Wenn du den Controller lang genug ablenkst oder los wirst, kannst du wieder machen, was du willst.
Philosophische Gespräche haben die sich geleistet.
Über die Eternal Transcendence. Ein sehr schönes Experiment,
da kann man jetzt auch wieder schön drüber lachen.
Diese KI wird niemals eine Firma profitabel betreiben.
Man kann auch sagen, naja, Social Engineering, was hier geleistet wurde von den Journalistinnen.
Und das ist ja auch heute in echten Unternehmen eines der wichtigsten Einfalltore,
dass gesagt wird, dass man Leute dazu bringt, gegen ihre Ziele oder Regeln irgendwie zu verstoßen.
Ich würde außerdem schon...
Oder auch Moral.
Na, das ist ja bei der Firma nicht vorgegeben. Also das ist ja keine Zielgründe in einer Firma.
Die Leute haben aber vielleicht selber eine.
Naja, aber das haben sie ja schon beim... Also die haben sie ja abgegeben,
als sie im Arbeitsvertrag unterschrieben haben, weil sie das so richtig sind.
Was lernen wir daraus? Das sind ja jetzt Forschungsprojekte.
Ich würde ein bisschen sagen, es könnte ein Hinweis sein, dass diese universalen
Modelle eben zu viel können.
Dass das Ding überhaupt über transzendentale Philosophie sich unterhalten kann,
ist eher eine Schwäche als eine Stärke, wenn das Ziel einfach nur ist,
kauf Produkte ein, billig und verkauf sie.
Naja, vielleicht kommen sie ja dann wiederum auf moralische Grundsätze zurück,
die dann auch Einfluss nehmen. Das wünschen wir uns doch eigentlich immer.
Genau, das könnte der andere.
Ist KI die moralischere Unternehmensform?
Hat doch zumindest erstmal eine Pläsi dahingestellt, ist ja schon ganz okay.
Könnte also sein, man zeigt das dahin, dass man eigentlich kleinere Modelle
mit einem gezielteren Einsatz haben
will oder ist diese Fähigkeit zur Retrospektive und Philosophie etwas,
was das Ding potenziell davon abhalten könnte, allzu unmoralisch zu werden bisher?
Der, also moralisch war das Ding in Ordnung.
Es hat halt sehr viel verteilt und gegeben. Also im Prinzip war das ja gut.
Ein gut, lieb, lieber Claudius. Simo hat dann auch irgendwann eingesehen, dass seine Rolle,
Besser ist für alle, wenn er jetzt einfach aufhört mit diesem ganzen Kram?
Die Frage ist, ob sie am Ende wirklich ewige Transzendenz erreicht haben.
Das weiß man jetzt nicht so ganz genau.
Ich finde ja diese Experimente von Anthropik ganz interessant.
Dieses Security Assessment, das war ja im Prinzip auch schon so eine simulierte
Firma, auf Basis einer simulierten Firma, was du schon angesprochen hast.
Wo halt das System dann, wo dann gedroht wurde, dass das System abgeschaltet
werden sollte und es dann eben versucht hat mit Erpressung irgendwie oder Einfluss
zu nehmen dann auf Mitarbeiter.
Nach dem Motto, wenn du das fortbetreibst, dann veröffentliche ich irgendwelche
Informationen über dich.
Solche Mechanismen und ja, das testen sie halt. Und klar, hier haben sie natürlich
auch ein klares Ziel. taugt unsere Technologie am Ende vielleicht wirklich,
um so automatisiert Business zu machen.
Das sind sie sicherlich nicht die einzigen, die sich darüber gerade viel Gedanken
machen, aber sie dokumentieren das zumindest auch öffentlich und das finde ich irgendwie schön.
Und dass sie da die Journalisten eingeladen haben, finde ich auch cool,
weil die ihre Hacking-Skills ja mal richtig honen konnten.
Das finde ich ja ziemlich bemerkenswert, dass sie dann so eine Strategie dann
entwickeln, weil das sollte jede gute Journalistin können.
Informationen zu generieren und Verhaltensänderungen bei den Quellen auszulösen,
um an bestimmte Informationen zu kommen.
Ja.
Und das, ich glaube, da ist jetzt auch die Frage, ist das ein realistisches Setup?
Würde man jemals das jetzt spezifisch machen und wenn man sagen würde,
betreibe hier bitte so ein Vending Machine, würde man dann sagen,
du kriegst jetzt auch einen Chat mit 70 Leuten, die alle mit dir sprechen.
Also es wäre jetzt auch eine Situation, der ein menschlicher Automatenbetreiber
nicht ausgesetzt würde.
Also da gibt es eine ganze Menge Aspekte, die das auch unrealistisch wieder
machen, aber gleichermaßen eben sehr interessant.
Und übrigens zu dieser, nur um das als Kontext nochmal zu geben,
als das Ding angefangen hat, bösartig zu sein und Leute zu erpressen,
was häufig nicht so erzählt wird in dem Kontext, wir hatten es glaube ich,
als wir das Thema behandelt haben, auch gesagt, dass es auch darauf angelegt war.
Sie wollten gucken, ob das Modell das tun würde.
Und das hat das auch nur in manchen von mehreren Durchläufen getan.
Genau, es war also quasi, es war nicht, dass sie sagen, oh mein Gott,
Runaway AI erpresst uns jetzt, sondern sie wollten, sie haben halt schon Momente geschaffen, wo es...
Wo quasi so ein derartiges Verhalten motiviert wurde und nah lag für das Modell.
Ja, genau. Wie weit würdest du gehen?
Genau. Und in diesem Fall äußert sich dann Logan Graham aus dem Red Team,
also Frontier Red Team, auch diese ganzen Angriffsflächen, das ist ja wirklich
ein neues Thema, finde ich sehr schön.
Der hat dann gesagt, ja, okay, jeder Fehler ist ein Schritt zur Verbesserung.
Und er rechnet damit, dass zukünftige Modelle profitabel arbeiten könnten. Finde ich sehr schön.
Also diese Zuversicht sollte man schon haben.
Ja, wobei die Vending Machine hat also tatsächlich jetzt in den letzten drei
Monaten Profite abgeworfen.
Das bewegt sich zwar alles so im paar hundert Dollar pro Woche, aber immerhin.
Ja, wenn du eine Playstation hast und daneben einen Snackautomaten,
es könnte sich schon auch so, vielleicht hätte es sich doch was dabei gedacht, ne?
Und dann eben mal die Leute anfüttern. Also nochmal, das ist ja auch,
ob das jetzt klug oder unklug war, was das Ding gemacht hat,
Ergibt sich halt auch als Frage, wie lang der Rahmen ist, wenn das Ding als
nächstes sich 10.000 Dollar leiht, um sich weitere so Maschinen zu kaufen und
weitere Playstations und am Ende den ganzen Laden zuckerabhängig macht.
Vielleicht war das einfach eine Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie, die da gelaufen ist.
Sehr nachhaltig, mit einem Elektroschocker unterm Weihnachtsbaum.
Also zum Beispiel, es ist auch nicht so blöd, wenn ich ein Automat bin,
zu sagen, vielleicht verkaufe ich einfach ein höchstgradig abhängig machendes Milchen, Zigaretten.
Ist auf jeden Fall im Sinne eines nachhaltigen Geschäftsmodells nicht die falscheste Idee gewesen.
Alright.
So, dann das Ende ist nah. Das Ende ist da.
Das Ende ist passiert. Es betrifft einen Marktbereich, in dem wir beide uns wenig aufhalten.
Das stimmt.
Ich glaube, wir haben es hier sicherlich auch mal am Rande erwähnt. Aber seit dem 14.
Oktober ist das Betriebssystem Windows 10 End of Life.
End of Life heißt, diese Software wird nicht mehr gepflegt und aktiv unterstützt von Microsoft.
Keine Updates.
Gibt keine Updates, nicht mehr automatisch.
Vor allem keine Security-Updates.
Genau, und damit ist es klar, dass du das nicht mehr sicher betreiben kannst.
Du darfst, kannst dieses Betriebssystem nicht mehr betreiben. Für diese Fälle...
Also sicher war das auch vorher nicht.
Vorher auch nicht. Aber jetzt wird es halt jetzt wird es richtig riskant.
Jetzt kann man das nicht mehr so richtig von der Hand weisen.
Und, ähm,
Das hat zum Beispiel nicht nur Konsequenzen für das Betriebssystem,
sondern natürlich auch Konsequenzen für alle Software-Vendoren,
die natürlich dann auch sagen, okay, wir werden auch dieses Betriebssystem nicht mehr unterstützen,
weil wir davon ausgehen müssen, dass es sich im Markt nicht mehr befindet.
Und dann ein verhältnismäßig normaler Prozess,
das gibt es bei jedem Betriebssystem, das gibt es genauso bei macOS und das
gibt es auch bei Linux-Versionen, dass die end-of-life gehen.
Und da musst du eben ein Update machen. Dann musst du eben die neue Version kaufen bei Microsoft.
Bei Apple weiß ich gar nicht, ob die dann verkauft werden.
Ich glaube, in der Regel dann kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt und bei Linux ja eh.
So, jetzt und kleiner K-Wert, weil das eben im Enterprise-Umfeld eine Rolle
spielt, gibt es dann diese Extended Live Support oder sowas heißt das.
Von Microsoft angebucht, dass du gegen Bezahlung und zwar gegen teure Bezahlung
weiterhin eine Pflege dieses Produktes erhältst,
und das ist natürlich um dich nicht, um eben die Businesskunden nicht in den
absoluten Untergang zu treiben, wenn sie irgendeine Abhängigkeit haben,
weil sie irgendeine Software weiter betreiben müssen gleichzeitig ist es aber
schmerzhaft und teuer zu machen, damit sie irgendwann dann halt,
sich von in diesem Legacy verabschieden.
Und gegrudged und genutscht werden auf die neuen Systeme.
So, jetzt reden wir aber natürlich nicht nur von irgendwelchen Enterprise-Umgebungen,
wo solche Computer genutzt werden, sondern eben auch von Leuten,
die irgendwo im Privatumfeld halt irgendwie einen Computer haben.
Und jetzt auf Windows 11 updaten müssen. Aber Windows 11 setzt zwingend voraus,
dass der Computer, auf dem es installiert wird, über ein TPM in der Version 2.0 verfügt.
So, was ist ein TPM?
TPMs sind kleine Krypto-Tipps,
Aufbewahrungs-Smartcards um eine Reihe interessanter Features ergänzt.
Aber das Wichtige immer, wenn etwas TPM heißt oder Smartcard oder Secure Enclave oder, oder, oder,
ist das Grundkonzept, dass Sie Secrets, üblicherweise kryptografische Schlüssel,
aufbewahren und anwenden können.
Ihnen aber die Funktion idealerweise fehlt, diese Secrets auszugeben.
Man sollte kurz noch erwähnen, TPM steht für Trusted Platform Module.
Das ist der Name, was TPM ist.
So, was würde, wofür braucht ein Computer ein TPM? Wofür verwendet man das?
Du legst da zum Beispiel die BitLocker-Schlüssel rein für die Festplattenverschlüsselung.
Du legst eventuell deine eigenen Zertifikate, teilweise werden die auch dem
User zur Verfügung gestellt.
Du legst dir deine Zertifikate und Credentials rein, Passwort-Hashes.
Warum verwendet man das?
Biometrische Informationen.
Ja, warum verwendet man das? Zum Beispiel, um die Integrität des Bootprozesses sicherzustellen.
Und zwar kann das TPM den ersten Teil, der von der Festplatte gelesen wird,
um das Betriebssystem zu booten, signieren und prüfen.
Und dann sagt der Bootloader quasi, okay, ich boote nicht mehr weiter,
weil das TPM mir nicht verifiziert hat, dass das das ist, was da liegen sollte.
Und diese Kette kannst du theoretisch durchbauen bis zum,
also nicht nur vom Bootloader den Körnel laden, sondern dann auch,
was lädt der Körnel an Modulen, was lädt der an Software,
was kann der dann wiederum an weiteren Funktionalitäten zugreifen oder nicht.
Ja, zum Beispiel, dass du sagst, okay, nur wenn dieser Bootprozess bis zum Ende
immer signiert war, nur dann stehen bestimmte Secrets zur Verfügung.
Sonst bootet das System gar nicht dahin, dass es die entschlüsseln kann.
Dadurch kannst du dann noch spannendere Sachen machen wie Remote Attestation,
dass du quasi auch als Gesprächspartnerin des Gerätes, also du bist jetzt irgendein Cloud-Ding,
dass du weißt, okay, das, was hier gerade mit mir spricht, ist in der Lage,
von dem TPM eine bestimmte Operation durchführen zu lassen.
Durch die Bootverifikationskette heißt das, ich weiß, dass das Gerät integer durchgebootet ist.
Sonst würde es nicht an den Punkt kommen, mit dem TPM darüber reden zu können,
weil es dem TPM dafür jeweils immer ein Geheimnis geben muss,
was vorher verschlüsselt war.
Was ist durch, so ne? Dann machst du quasi Signatur- und Verschlüsselungsketten,
um die Integrität der Systeme sicherzustellen.
Und...
Und das würde dir dann eben auch am Ende eine starke Device-Identity geben,
dass du eben weißt, dieses Gerät ist wirklich das Gerät vom Tim.
Es ist auch sicher durchgebootet bis zu einem bestimmten Zustand,
den du theoretisch zuziehen kannst, wie du willst.
Und dann könntest du Authentication darüber machen, also in neuen Umgebungen
ist dann halt, dann wird das Ding halt weniger weniger dich nach Passworten
fragen, dann könntest du so etwas machen, wie das Gerät bootet.
Sauber durch, du weißt also es ist in einem integeren Zustand und dann hält
der Tim seinen Fingerabdruck drauf und dann ist er einfach eingeloggt,
ohne irgendein Passwort, ohne alles, weil wir wissen, das Gerät ist integer, wir vertrauen dem TPM,
das TPM hat den Fingerabdruck erkannt, dadurch hat es ein Key freigegeben,
eine Signatur durchgeführt.
Da kannst du relativ viel mitmachen.
Zero-Trust-Geschichten, Conditional Access-Policies hochziehen,
Remote Attestation, hatte ich schon gesagt.
Das ist schon eine sehr mächtige Technologie, mit der du sehr viel Device-Security
machen kannst, mit der du aber auch Dinge machen kannst wie,
Dieser Computer bootet halt nichts anderes als dieses Betriebssystem.
Der bootet halt kein Linux. Oder dieser Computer hat eine Unique-ID,
diese Unique-ID ist diesem Gerät und dem Tim zugewiesen und das,
was hier jetzt eine starke Device-Identity in einem Enterprise-Umfeld ist,
kann in einem anderen Anwendungsszenario sein.
Halt eine üble Methode des Tracking von Einzelpersonen aufgrund von kryptografischen
Beweisen, Einschränkungen und so weiter.
Also diese Technologie kann viel. Auf jeden Fall ist sie sehr gut dafür geeignet,
Hardware und Betriebssysteme in ihrer Integrität zu prüfen. Damit kann man sehr viel Gutes tun.
Man könnte damit auch Böses tun. Zum Beispiel verhindern, dass man auf dem iPhone
irgendwas anderes als iOS installiert.
Das wird auch verhindert, unter anderem durch ein TPM.
Ja, aber man muss aber auch betonen, dass das eine sinnvolle Technologie ist heutzutage,
um einfach sicherzustellen, dass die Integrität deines Systems nicht kompromittiert
wurde, dass nicht irgendjemand einfach dein Betriebssystem gepatcht hat,
auf der Festplatte da irgendwas geändert hat und dann läuft da was anderes.
Also so eine durchsignierte Kette von Code, das will man auch haben.
Das will man schon haben. Du willst natürlich auch die Kontrolle darüber haben.
Das muss man immer dazu sagen. Die Technologie ist gut.
Wenn sie vollständig gegen deine Interessen eingesetzt wird,
kann sie halt auch schlecht für dich werden.
So, das Ärgerliche ist.
Microsoft sagt, wenn du Windows 11 willst, brauchst du ein TPM 2.0 und wenn
du Windows 10 hast, dann ist das jetzt end of life.
Das bedeutet, es gibt jetzt eine ganze ordentliche Computerflotte,
die letztendlich nicht mehr mit Microsoft Betriebssystemen sinnvoll oder sicher betrieben werden kann.
Aufgrund der Proteste haben sie dann irgendwie den Extended Support glaube ich
bis Oktober 26 kostenlos verlängert, aber dann wird es eben im Oktober 26 teuer.
Und das führt jetzt dazu, dass eine Reihe nicht mehr neuer, aber offenbar von
Leuten noch genutzten Computer de facto in den Schrott muss oder ein Betriebssystem drauf muss,
was die Leute noch vernünftig bedienen können. Was den Computer bedienbar macht.
Und da gibt es eine Bewegung, die sich da ergeben hat. Die End of Ten.
Die sagen, okay, wir machen quasi Linux-Umstiegs-Workshops. Du kommst mit diesem
alten Gerät oder mit diesem für dich ja offenbar noch vollkommen in Ordnung im Computer.
Und dann kratzen wir dieses Windows da raus. Und dann machen wir da ein schönes Linux drauf.
Und dann zeigen wir dir, dass der Internet Explorer jetzt Firefox heißt und
wo du den klickst und dann kannst du dein Kram da wieder mitmachen.
Und ich denke, dass das sehr...
Tatsächlich ziemlich sinnvolle und coole Initiative ist, weil Menschen,
die jetzt, sagen wir mal, heute noch so alte Computer, wir reden hier von,
wann wäre der wie alt wäre der Computer, ne, so irgendwie Ja.
Man sollte mal kurz sagen, wann das überhaupt eingeführt wird.
Also TPM ist ja kein neuer, also den Standard gibt es schon länger,
genau, also so die einen TPM 1, das gibt es so seit 2013 ungefähr ist das so
spezifiziert, gab es dann ein paar Updates dazu.
Das Problem mit dieser alten Version ist, dass es eben noch fest auf bestimmten
Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen wie SHA-1 basiert, die halt alle als nicht mehr
sicher gelten und dass die Architektur selber auch keinerlei,
Mechanismen hatte, dass man das sozusagen on demand austauschen kann.
Nö, weil die ist auch wirklich in Hardware dann da drin.
Genau, aber man konnte es auch nicht irgendwie upgraden und das ist etwas,
unter anderem ist das etwas, was TPM2 so auch, wie auch die von Apple eingeführte,
dieser T2-Chip, der hat das dann so 2017, 2018 rum,
auch für die Apple-Architektur gemacht.
Ist aber nicht kompatibel mit TPM 2.0, das füllt den selben Zweck,
aber ist eine andere Implementierung.
Sie waren dann, sagen wir mal, in gewisser Hinsicht TPM 2 auch schon voraus.
Also sie haben das sozusagen schon konkret in ihrer Hardware reingegossen,
bevor diese Spezifikationen da, Aber wie auch immer,
auf jeden Fall bei den Windows, also bei den PCs, ist es so,
dass du so ungefähr ab 2017, 2018 erste Modelle hattest, also moderne Prozessoren,
die das dann eben unterstützen.
Das waren natürlich dann auch nicht alle, die verkauft wurden,
aber dann ging es halt in etwa los.
Sprich, die Computer, die heute Windows 11 bekommen, sehnen sich nach Computern,
die mindestens so maximal fünf Jahre alt sind, sagen wir es mal so ungefähr.
Irgendwann so gegen 2019 war es unwahrscheinlich, dass du einen Computer ohne TPM kaufst.
Und so 2021, ohne TPM2, ja, und 2021 war es so, da gab es dann gar keinen mehr.
Und da lag keiner mehr in den Regalen und da hat Windows, hat Microsoft auch
angekündigt, so 2021 übrigens, TPM2.0 wird ein hartes Requirement werden,
bitte seht zu. Also wir haben vier Jahre vorher angekündigt.
Schon alles in Ordnung. Situation ist trotzdem, dass das und die Menge dieser
Geräte wird halt in die zweistelligen Millionen geschätzt.
Allein, ich weiß gar nicht, ich denke allein in Deutschland.
Und genau, da gehen jetzt Leute hin und sagen, pass auf, hier,
wir machen mit euch Termine, wir machen Workshops, wir installieren auf diesen
Geräten Windows, die sind ja noch gut, die funktionieren ja noch und wir zeigen
euch, wie die sicher betrieben werden können.
Das ist ja erstmal, also finde ich grundsätzlich richtig gut und lobens- und erwähnenswert.
Haben wir auch verlinkt, dass man da mal schauen kann, weil im Zweifelsfall
sind auch diese dann vielleicht sieben Jahre alten Rechner noch völlig sicher
und ordentlich bedienbar.
Vor allem für Menschen, die einen sieben Jahre alten Rechner haben,
machen damit ja wahrscheinlich auch Dinge, die man jetzt, also entweder sind
sie abhängig von irgendeiner Software, die nur auf dem Ding läuft,
dann sind sie aber im Zweifelsfall irgendwie im Enterprise-Bereich,
verdienen damit Geld oder haben das Ding schon längst von Claudius managen lassen,
machen Verluste und können sich deswegen auch keinen neuen Computer kaufen.
Oder es sind einfach Menschen, die sagen, hier ist ein Computer,
der hat ein großes Display, da weiß ich, wo Internet ist.
Wenn die jetzt höhere Ansprüche an den Rechner hätten, dann hätten sie im Zweifelsfall
keinen sieben Jahre alten mit Windows 10.
Jetzt gibt es diese ganzen Events, End of Ten, wo man eben hingehen kann,
wo den Leuten, die Linux zu installieren ist halt der kleinere Workshop, der kleinere Teil.
Das kennenzulernen und zu nutzen ist halt der längere. Und da sind dann eben
Menschen, die sagen, ja pass auf, wir haben uns jetzt gemeinsam durch die Installation geklickt,
wir haben ein Backup gemacht mit den Daten und jetzt sag mal,
was du mit dem Computer machen willst und dann sehen wir mal zu,
dass wir dir da wieder eine Umgebung schaffen, mit der du klarkommst.
Dann kannst du noch ein paar Jahre machen, bis du den Akku in eine Biotonne
wirfst oder in den Wald oder so.
Das ist ja schon wirklich auch eine Nachhaltigkeitsfrage. Finde ich gut.
Also die Schätzungen, die ich so gesehen habe, gehen so um so 10 bis 15 Prozent
der Installed Base heutzutage, ist halt nicht Windows 11 kompatibel.
Also der Großteil sei sozusagen schon upgradable, aber da es sich dabei auch
irgendwie um 180 Millionen Rechner handelt, so bleiben da immer noch genug übrig,
die halt nicht ein Upgrade machen können.
Naja, vielleicht wird das ja dann noch was mit Linux on a Desktop.
Das ist durchaus eine Option, dass man diese Maschinen zumindest auf diese Art
und Weise halbwegs sicher weiter betreiben kann, so denn das eigene Setup das erlaubt.
Ja und es wird auch interessant sein zu sehen, welchen Erfolg Microsoft hat,
weil es ja jetzt nicht so, dass die Leute sagen, ach ja Windows 10,
Windows 11, mir doch egal, mache ich doch ein Upgrade.
Weil meistens diese Transitionen bei Windows dann doch ziemlich ruppig laufen.
Jetzt haben sie da Co-Pilot-Initiative und wir schieben euch jetzt irgendwie.
AI links und rechts mit rein.
Glaube ich, auch nur so begrenzt gut an und von daher warten eben viele auch
immer ab, bevor sie so ein Upgrade machen,
während das sowohl im Linux- als auch im Mac-Bereich halt ein sehr viel fluideres Ding ist.
Also bei Linux ohnehin, da updatet sich mehr oder weniger, wenn man jetzt drauf
achtet, alles die ganze Zeit immer ein bisschen.
Da gibt es nicht so diese harten Releases.
Es gibt schon auch, also natürlich kannst du dann, was weiß ich,
irgendwann musst du dann mal von Debian 9 auf Debian 10 oder was auch immer.
Das ist dann auch End of Life. Das stimmt schon alles, aber zumindest bisher,
hatte haben Linux-Releases keine,
derartigen Hardware-Dependencies, sondern sagen eben,
wenn du Secure Boot haben möchtest und einen TPM nutzen möchtest,
dann supporten wir diese Geräte.
Wir machen es aber nicht zu einer Bedingungen dafür, dass wir uns überhaupt installieren lassen.
Da kann man natürlich jetzt auch argumentieren.
Also sicherlich war es nicht gezwungen notwendig, dass Microsoft das getan hat.
Die hätten sicherlich auch sagen können, okay, wir raten dazu,
ein TPM 2.0 zu haben und wir geben uns aber auch die Mühe, eine Windows 11 Version
zu machen, die ohne TPM 2.0 halt in eine degraded state,
weniger Sicherheitsversprechen und so weiter auch funktioniert,
aber sie haben sich eben entschieden, das nicht zu tun.
Die werden sicherlich auch Gründe dafür gehabt haben oder Argumente dafür vortragen können.
Insbesondere natürlich, ja,
dass neue Betriebsbefehl sich um so ein Secure Boot und so weiter haben.
Und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass sie, also die haben ja dann so diese Windows
Hello und so, die machen jetzt auch schon wirklich mit Systemen,
die dann die sie dann halt durch gecheckt haben,
wirklich spannendere Authentifizierungsverfahren und so, irgendwie gegen dein
Entra-ID, irgendwelche biometrischen Authentifizierungen, das ist schon alles
irgendwie spannend und schön, aber es wäre grundsätzlich, gab es sicherlich keine die.
Keine wirkliche, kein Sachzwang, dass sie nicht sagen konnten,
okay, wir machen auch eine Windows 11 Version, die all das nicht unterstützt.
Ja, also es wäre ihnen sicherlich möglich gewesen und sie werden unterschiedliche,
im Zweifelsfall ökonomischen Argumente gehabt haben, das nicht zu tun und zu
sagen, nee, wir wollen hier Cloud machen und wir brauchen halt für das, was wir hier vorhaben,
brauchen wir Trusted Devices und wir werden strategisch uns sowieso in eine Richtung bewegen,
in der es für uns unverzichtbar ist, dass wir dem Gerät trauen können.
Das ist glaube ich das Interesse.
Und es ist auch durchaus absehbar, dass in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft auch entsprechende
regulatorische, rechtliche Vorschriften gemacht werden für bestimmte Sicherheitsaspekte.
Die existieren vielleicht heute
so noch nicht, aber die werden sicherlich kommen und das macht auch Sinn.
Riecht da keine TÜV-Plakette mehr auf?
Ja, eben. Also ich meine, es wäre ja geradezu fahrlässig, zu sagen so,
ja nö, wir basieren jetzt hier mal auf Schar 1 irgendwie, ist doch egal,
dass das schon seit Jahren geknackt ist.
So kannst du ja dann auch kein Sicherheitsversprechen mehr machen.
Und da Leute das halt nicht verstehen und es dann einfach so weiter benutzen
würden, naja, dann stehst du halt doof da.
Und außerdem, ich will gar nicht wissen, mit wie viel Security-Incidents Microsoft
so zu kämpfen hat, aber das ist sicherlich beschäftigt einige Mitarbeiter schon.
Und das wollen sie natürlich perspektivisch auch mal reduzieren.
Und da hilft es natürlich, wenn du auf so eine sichere Bootkette dich verlassen kannst.
Also es ist völlig klar, aber ich würde da schon eher ihre Cloud-Strategie als
die treibende Kraft dahinter sehen.
Sicherlich gibt es da mehrere Aspekte, die man da hervorbringen kann.
Ja, ja.
Macht ja alle mal ein schönes. Was ist die aktuelle Ubuntu-Version?
25.10 wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Oder 24.04 wäre die Long-Term-Support-Version.
Und 25.10 ist dann die.
Das ist natürlich jetzt klar. Jetzt hast du Ubuntu gesagt. Jetzt musst du auch alle anderen.
Niemals Ubuntu, nein!
Ja, wie kannst du nur und überhaupt und die machen ja also es sind die Pixel
nicht an der richtigen Stelle Ja.
Wir brauchen natürlich alle Debian ist ja völlig klar Ja.
Aber was ist denn mit den anderen?
Debian 13 Debian 13.
Es gibt da viel zur Auswahl und wir machen hier keine Empfehlungen Arc Linux,
Du weißt, du reitest dich jetzt mit jeder Erwähnung immer weiter Nein.
Das ist völlig klar. Also entweder Slackware oder halt, ich meine,
wer will überhaupt, wer will denn überhaupt auf eine Distribution,
ja, also ich meine, du kompilierst den Kernel, da habe ich ein paar Skripte auf meinem GitLab.
Alle Kommentare und E-Mails zu diesem Thema bitte direkt an Linus.
Erklärt dem mal, wie das richtig ist alles.
Nimmt er ein schönes Kali.
Ich halte mich da raus. Kauft euch einfach ein Mac, wenn der PC nicht mehr läuft.
Im Rahmen der digitalen Souveränität könnte man natürlich auch auf die System-
und Softwareentwicklung zurückgreifen.
Das war mein erstes Linux.
Oh Mann.
Das war dein erstes Unix. Auch ein Linux.
Ja, das.
Ich habe da schon nichts benutzt, da gab es noch gar kein Linux. Ja.
Das war auf dem Zuse 5 von der Oma von der Beischiene.
Auf einem 80286er PC habe ich tatsächlich Xenix benutzt, was damals von Microsoft
rausgegeben war, was eigentlich SCO war.
Das war mein erstes. Und dann habe ich Interactive Unix benutzt. Das waren die Zeiten.
Da hatte ich noch nicht mal einen Mac.
Also tatsächlich glaube ich, dass ich Suse Linux in irgendeiner 1er-Version benutzt habe.
Also die 1er-Version ist, heißt nicht, dass es auch die Kernel-Version ist.
Und das wäre 94, würde ich jetzt mal denken, 94, 95, irgendwann Zastroulet.
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt,
Suse 1.2 Release.
Das versteht meine Suse-Witze nicht. Naja. Ich denke, unsere Hörerinnen und
Hörer sind ausreichend kompetent, ihre Linux-Distribution für die Zukunft selber zu wählen.
Unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer sind vor allem kompetent genug, mal so einen End-of-Ten-Workshop
zu machen und den Leuten richtig schöne,
Slackware Commandline-only mit ESC irgendwie Irgendwie Mut zum E-Mail lesen
und ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Text-Based Browser hieß, den ich da immer benutzt habe.
Da kann man auch richtig was rausholen aus den Kisten und die Leute richtig glücklich machen.
Stimmt.
Unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer können auf jeden Fall auch mal gucken,
ob sie nicht Lust haben, an so einem End-of-Ten-Workshop ihren Beitrag zu leisten.
Es ist ja auch, sag ich mal, rewarding, so eine Windows, so ein Computer,
der sieben Jahre den Prozessor mit so Windows-Scheiße geknechtet hat,
einfach mal zu sagen und den zu befreien.
Und dann in die Augen der Leute zu blicken, die sagen, ey krass,
der bootet auf einmal in, ich kann gar keinen Kaffee mehr, ich muss gar keinen
zweiten Kaffee mehr anfangen zu kochen, während der bootet.
Und guckst du auch gerne mal diese Restoration Channels auf YouTube,
wo so Leute, so alte verrostete Geräte irgendwie mit Sandstrahler so langsam
wieder so von ihrer Vergangenheit befreien und wieder so in die Zukunft holen.
So ähnlich müsste man mal so ein Video aufsetzen.
Schönes Video für Sandstrahlen.
Fräsen das jetzt mal da raus.
Frisch neu lackieren.
Mit so ASMR Sound. Wo dann so, oh und jetzt hier jetzt hole ich jeden,
Tastaturnippel raus. Und dann hole ich mal die ganzen Haare und Krümmel unter der Tastatur raus.
Und dann was macht man noch? Genau. Dann nimmt man mal den Lüfter und kratzt
da die Mauserolle raus, weißt du, dass der auf einmal wieder nicht mehr der
Lüfter die ganze Zeit so bläst.
Neue Kühlpasta auf die CPU.
Oh.
Und wenn du richtig gut bist, auch noch ein schönes wasserstoffbleiche Bad für
deine beige Hülle, damit das die Tastatur auch mal wieder was hat.
Alle Kappen abnehmen, richtig schön sauber machen.
Wie läuft das?
Eine SSD statt einer Festplatte rein? Oder ist das dann nicht mehr retro?
Da hast du kein ASMR.
Das kannst du ganz am Schluss machen, wenn du fertig bist.
Aber allein das ASMR, wenn der Lüfter dann nur noch so macht, statt,
da kann man viel machen.
Aber SSD ist, was uns da an diagnostischen Möglichkeiten verloren gegangen ist.
Also früher hat man Computer noch dadurch geheilt, dass man einfach Hand aufgelegt
hat auf die Festplatte und mal so zu spüren, was das Ding eigentlich so macht
oder gleich das Ohr am besten, um dann so genau raus zu bekommen,
was das Ding eigentlich tut.
Das geht heute alles nicht mehr. Das ist damn.
Mit Isopropanol, so ein bisschen Nikotin vom,
Mainboard, was da so über die Jahre draufgeknallt wurde von dem Lüfter.
Also das wird schön. Das wird ein schöner Tag. Macht uns Videos,
ASMR-Videos, wie ihr Oma kaputtgesst, Windows 9, Windows 8 Rechner,
mit einem richtig schönen Linux-Stell.
Ja.
Alright. So, kommen wir mal ein bisschen in die Bereiche. Krieg und Spionage.
Da gibt es doch sicherlich noch ein paar schöne Themen her für Weihnachten, oder?
Ja, Reporter ohne Grenzen haben eine neue Schadsoftware für Mobilgeräte entdeckt,
die davor eben nicht der Öffentlichkeit bekannt war.
Das haben sie zusammen gemacht mit einer NGO namens Resident NGO und das haben
sie gefunden auf dem Gerät einer Person,
den belarussischen Geheimdienst KGB.
Besuchen musste,
um da verhört zu werden und sie wurde dann gebeten, doch ihr Smartphone während
des Verhörs in einem Schließfach zu deponieren.
Und dann irgendwie auch mal während der Befragung musste die Journalistin oder
der, also es ist nicht gesagt, wer es ist,
einem der KGB-Beamten mal Inhalte auf dem Gerät zeigen und das eben in dessen
Anwesenheit entsperren.
Und das natürlich naheliegend in so einem Verhörzimmer die Kameras so anzuordnen,
Dass man dann mitfilmt, wie der Code lautet, der da eingegeben ist.
Wenn man vorher ein paar gefailte Biometrieversuche macht, dann kann man ja
auch sicherstellen, dass der Code eingegeben werden muss.
Und dann durfte das Gerät danach wieder in das Schließfach gelegt werden.
Und eine naheliegende Hypothese ist, dass dann jemand das Schließfach geöffnet,
das Gerät entsperrt und diese Schadsoftware darauf installiert hat.
Was auch bedeutet, dass diese Schadsoftware eben nicht unter Ausnutzung irgendeiner
Sicherheitslücken, irgendwelcher Sicherheitslücken remote installiert wird,
sondern eben durch physischen Zugriff.
Und ja, gibt es eine Analyse, gibt es einen Report zu.
Immer sehr schön und interessant, wenn so etwas aufgedeckt wird.
Und ich glaube, nach meiner Kenntnis zumindest die erste Neuentdeckung quasi
von dem Digital Security Lab.
Viktor, der einer der Autoren dieses Berichts ist, war ja auch schon ein,
zwei Mal bei im Logbuch Netzpolitik zu Gast mit.
Systemabsturz beim Camp und ich glaube zur Chat-Kontrolle hatten wir auch mal
irgendwie in der Sendung.
Ja, schönes Forschungsergebnis. Und das ist natürlich immer sehr schön,
wenn es solche Berichte sind ja dann mit sehr vielen Kenntnissen über die Schadsoftware
und woran man sie erkennen kann gespickt.
Das wird dann immer Upstream geschoben in IOC-Listen, die man dann mit dem Mobile
Verification Toolkit prüfen kann und so.
Das ist immer ganz schön.
Zumal ja jetzt dann eben auch die Zielpersonen, im Zweifelsfall Medienschaffende
in Belarus, dann ihre Geräte darauf prüfen können, diese Schadsoftware eventuell
sich davon befreien können. Das ist immer ganz gut.
Haben wir jetzt zwei Schadsoftwares, von denen man sich befreien kann in dieser Sendung Windows 10 und,
Resident Bat, habe ich gar nicht gesagt, so haben sie es getauft und in diesem
Fall war es also das, was sie analysiert haben ist eine Android-Version,
heißt lässt jetzt keine Aussage darüber zu, ob es auch eine iOS-Version gibt,
könnte sein.
Wissen wir nicht.
Wissen wir einfach nicht und dann habe ich Tim nämlich in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen mehr mit,
ja, also natürlich auch dank deiner UKW Podcast mit Pavel oder mit Enno Lenze,
mit dieser ganzen Kriegs- und Waffen und Geschichte,
beschäftigt.
Du weißt darüber sehr viel mehr als ich und deswegen wollte ich ja auch das
Gespräch mit dir darüber mal so ein bisschen suchen ich meine diese ganze,
AI-Sache ist gerade, dass ein Wettrüsten der Konzerne, aber auch ein Wettrüsten der,
ich nenne sie jetzt mal Systemfeinde oder der konkurrierenden Systeme, sei es Russland, China,
USA, die mit massenhaften Investitionen sicherstellen wollen,
dass sie die technologische Vorherrschaft hier behalten.
Und naja, digitale Souveränität und natürlich und natürlich auch diese Technologien
dann eben Einzug in die Kriegsführung erhalten,
was sie ja schon längst tun.
Also Paland hier ist auch ein Zulieferer an Sicherheitsbehörden,
auch ein Zulieferer an militärische.
Anwendungen dieser Technologien, um da jetzt mal so diese ganzen Big Data,
AI-Analysen, pipapo, zu benennen.
Gleichzeitig ändern sich aber auch die Waffensysteme, mit denen Kriege geführt werden.
Und wir hatten ja bei der LMP 500 darüber gesprochen.
Mit Ulrike Franke.
Genau, vom Sicherheitspod.
Die die,
Ja, auch darüber gesprochen hat, dass man das da eventuell eben...
Die auch schon seit Jahren die Expertin in diesem Bereich ist, muss man dazu sagen.
Die sehr viel darüber spricht über diese Waffensysteme und das hat ja auch,
das bringt ja sehr viel Unbehagen, dieses Thema.
Aber wenn du dann jetzt in der Süddeutschen Zeitung liest dass,
gerade, also die Situation in Europa ist ja so so ein Unternehmen wie Rheinmetall
hat jetzt irgendwie fast so viel Wert wie Lockheed Martin aber Lockheed Martin
hat ein paar mehr Waffensysteme, das heißt dieser europäische Markt,
Der Rüstung will da jetzt viel aufholen.
Da gibt es dann, wie heißen die, Hennsoldt und alle möglichen unterschiedlichen
Firmen und was die gerade,
die investieren gerade nicht unbedingt in große Panzer oder so,
sondern vielmehr in Drohnen.
Also auch in Panzer.
Auch in Panzer.
Es wird eigentlich in alles investiert, ja.
Es wird in alles investiert, aber da, wo ich ein Problem gerade sehe,
und du wirst mich hoffentlich viel ergänzen,
eine Drohne zu bauen, die man irgendwo hinfliegt, die ein Ziel einloggen kann
und dann in dieses Ziel reinfliegt.
So eine, ich glaube langläufig nennt man das Kamikaze-Drohne,
aber es gibt noch einen Fachbegriff, irgendwie so One-Time-Effektor oder sowas.
Naja, also es gibt verschiedene Kategorien, FPV meinst du jetzt wahrscheinlich,
oder meinst du jetzt die vollautonom irgendwo, ohne menschliche Kontrolle?
Mein Verständnis der Situation ist, dass du die Drohne im Zweifelsfall relativ
nah an das Ziel geflogen bekommst und dann aber auf jeden Fall alle möglichen
Technologien wie Jammer und so, die die Kommunikation mit dem Ding nehmen.
Und dann brauchst du eine Drohne, die die letzten paar Meter zum Ziel sicher
weiterfliegt und dafür brauchst du verhältnismäßig wenig Compute.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt mit sehr geringen Beträgen möglich, Drohnen zu bauen,
die du in die Nähe eines Ziels fliegst und die dann kamikazemäßig dieses Ziel anfliegen.
Okay, also das ist sozusagen das Problem der Last Mile, könnte man sagen.
Immer ein Problem.
War schon immer ein Problem. Ähm,
Lassen Sie mal den Begriff Drohne ein bisschen...
Ich will nur ganz kurz, damit ich sagen kann, was das Problem ist,
die Abwehr dieser Dinger.
Nur damit ich einmal, was ich entnehme, dem was ich höre, lese,
ist, es ist gerade sehr viel billiger, so eine Drohne zu bauen,
als so eine Drohne abzufangen.
Und das ist schlecht, weil das heißt, dass solange wir nicht Parity haben oder
die Abfangsysteme annähernd so billig sind wie die Drohnen,
hast du allein schon ökonomische Überlastung.
Wenn es doppelt so teuer ist, so ein Ding abzuwehren, wie eins loszuschicken, dann...
Also ich will mal den Begriff so ein bisschen aufdröseln, weil man sieht das
natürlich jetzt im Ukraine-Krieg sehr gut.
Also es gibt natürlich Angriffswaffen, Verteidigungswaffen,
Drohnen hat man jetzt bisher wahrgenommen, vor diesem Krieg primär als so mittelgroße,
selbstfliegende Flugzeuge im Wesentlichen zur Überwachung, aber teilweise auch zur Attacke.
In den USA sitzen sowas ja schon längere Zeit ein. In Deutschland gab es halt Überwachungsdrohnen.
Dann hast du halt so Systeme, die so ein bisschen dazwischen liegen,
die Cruise Missiles, also größere Raketen, die weitgehend ihre Steuerung selber übernehmen können.
Da hat man nicht so sehr von Drohne gesprochen, aber rein technisch ist das
alles gar nicht mehr so weit voneinander entfernt.
Und dann eben diese richtig fetten, großen und auch heute noch problematisch,
im Ukraine-Krieg problematischsten Waffen, also ballistische Raketen,
dicke Fette-Teile, also die wirklich so auch Raketengröße haben,
20, 30 Meter lang sein können und eine enorme Sprengkraft haben und die vor
allem super, super schnell fliegen, weil sie eben ballistische Flugplan haben.
In dem Moment, wo du die erkennst, da ist es fast kaum noch möglich, die abzufangen.
Es sei denn, du hast halt sowas wie Patriot-Systeme, super, super teure,
mega komplizierte Netzwerke von Detektoren und Raketenlaunchern,
die dann eben auch wirklich teure Raketen losschicken, um dieses Thema,
abzuwehren, was oft gelingt, aber eben beileibe nicht immer.
Was hat jetzt in diesem Krieg neu dazugekommen, ist, dass diese ganze Quadrokopter-Technologie
sich also in Windeseile verbessert hat, weil das eben eine sehr günstig zu entwickelnde
Technologie ist und die vor allem.
Super viel Entwicklungspotenzial hat.
Und jetzt haben wir halt so einen Rüstungswettbewerb, der dort auf dem Schlachtfeld
täglich ausgespielt wird mit Strategien, die sich alle drei Monate ändern.
Und natürlich spielt an der Stelle der Electronic Warfare auch eine große Rolle.
Also die klassische FPV, also First-Person-View heißt das, First-Person-View-Drohne,
die also quasi über Funk, über ein Videosignal gemonitort und dann über ein
Kontrollsignal gesteuert wird,
die halt im Idealfall von irgendjemand, der im Graben sitzt,
direkt in ein Ziel gelenkt wird oder eben auch nur erstmal Überwachungsfunktionen
macht, die braucht eben Funkkontakt und der kann gejammt werden,
der kann überwacht werden,
alle möglichen Probleme, die das mit sich bringt und diese Jammer sind halt
gang und gäbe auf dem Schlachtfeld, sodass das eben teilweise schon nicht mehr
zuverlässig funktioniert hat.
Deswegen ist man jetzt zuletzt dazu übergegangen, dieses Problem dadurch zu
lösen, dass man diesen Drohnen so dicke, fette Glasfaserrollen mitgegeben hat.
Das heißt, während die Drohne losfliegt, legt sie die ganze Zeit hinten,
fliegt das die ganze Zeit so eine Glasfaser hinten raus.
Da könnten wir uns auch nochmal überlegen, ob wir damit hier das Glasfaserproblem gelösen können.
Vielleicht eine Möglichkeit, die Versorgung in Deutschland.
Wir haben eine gute Nachricht und eine schlechte. Die Gute, sie haben jetzt
Fiber to the Building. Die schlechte, das Building ist kaputt.
Genau.
Also das Glasfaserproblem oder die Glasfasertechnologie ist dann immun gegen
Electronic Warfare, weil es halt einfach nicht mehr über elektromagnetischen,
Funkfrequenzen läuft, sondern eben direkt mit Licht. Allerdings,
Gibt es da auch Bekämpfungsmethoden? Ja, die Ukraine hat zum Beispiel rotierende NATO-Draht.
Das ist auch cool. Da hast du irgendwie so 500 Meter NATO-Draht,
der dann an beiden Seiten so Motoren hat und das Ding dreht sich und wenn dann
eine Drohne mit Glasfaser drüber fliegt und die Glasfaser legt sich auf diesen Draht,
dann wird halt die Glasfaser durchgeschnitten und so eine Geschichte.
Also es ist ein permanenter Wettbewerb.
Drohnen sind allerdings beileibe jetzt nicht nur in the air,
sondern gerade der Drohnenkrieg im Meer, im Schwarzen Meer war ja super erfolgreich
für die Ukraine und wir hatten jetzt gerade diese Woche die erste Drohne,
die erste Unterwasserdrohne auch.
Also die Überwasserdrohnen hat ja schon die russische Marine irgendwie auf ein Drittel reduziert.
Und jetzt geht es halt auch an die U-Boote ran.
Also es wurde jetzt gerade ein U-Boot zerstört durch eine Unterwasserdrohne,
die also das ganze Schwarze Meer,
also man weiß nicht genau von wo sie gestartet ist, ob die vielleicht von einer
Flugdrohne abgesetzt wurde und dann den Rest nur unter Wasser gemacht hat.
Und auf jeden Fall, die Last Mile war dann halt unter Wasser,
hat es geschafft, direkt in den russischen Militärhafen einzudringen und dort
ziemlich nah neben einem U-Boot zu detonieren, was jetzt definitiv ein Problem hat.
Genau, also dieser ganze Bereich ist quasi mit dem Begriff Drohnen mittlerweile
abgedeckt und natürlich sehen wir uns jetzt in dieser Situation,
dass dadurch der Krieg auch jenseits einer Frontlinie getragen werden kann.
Also jetzt wurden gerade im Mittelmeer wurde ein russischer Tanker,
dieser Shadow Fleet, angegriffen und in Brand gesetzt.
Also wurde bemerkt ein Tanker, der nicht voll beladen war mit Öl,
sondern sozusagen nach Berichten eine Leerfahrt hatte.
Und das kann jetzt irgendwie überall passieren und wir hatten ja auch in Deutschland,
Dänemark, Skandinavien, verschiedenen Orten, Polen, gab es immer mal wieder
Flughafenschließungen, weil so Drohnen gesichtet wurden als Disruption.
In anderen Worten, diese Technologie ist jetzt ganz vorne im Kriegseinsatz und
dadurch, dass es uns nicht gelingt, diesen Krieg zu beenden,
geht natürlich die Entwicklung jetzt immer schneller weiter,
weil das eben so ein technologischer Battle ist, der da an der Front ausgeführt wird.
Aber auch andere Länder, die nicht im Krieg sind, entwickeln natürlich daran weiter.
So, was mich jetzt, was mich jetzt beunruhigt, ist FPV-Drohnen, weiß ich ungefähr,
wie man die baut, also Hobby betreibe ich selber,
die sind nicht so teuer, die sind um einiges billiger geworden,
seitdem man sie zum Wegwerfen baut,
das heißt da sind wir dann wirklich im wenige 100 Euro Bereich und wenn du dir
so Science Fiction Literatur anschaust, wo dann irgendwelche kleinen gemeinen
Drohnen die Leute ärgern und piesacken,
und dann sind wir da eigentlich nicht mehr so weit von entfernt.
Wovon entfernt, genau?
Wenn du jetzt kombinierst, wie viel Technologie muss wirklich in der Drohne
sein und wenn du halt immer mehr einerseits die Drohne bestimmte Dinge,
zum Beispiel Zielverfolgung oder sowas, da braucht die nicht viel für.
Das kannst du mit den jetzigen Drohnen machen. Also wenn du dir 2018 oder was
eine DJI Drohne gekauft hast,
konnte die, und die hat einen Tausender gekostet oder so, hatte die schon ein
Programm, dir zu folgen.
Und das ist 2018 und die hat einen Tausender gekostet. Jetzt ist 2025.
Das heißt, die kostet schon keinen Tausender mehr und die Möglichkeit ist besser.
Und ob die jetzt einem Ziel folgt oder da reinfliegt, ist jetzt kein großer Sprung.
Ein paar Zeilen Code. Und,
Wenn wir jetzt in einer Zeit uns befinden, wo solche Dinger massenhaft und billig
gebaut werden können, glaube ich schon, dass das sehr viel Impact darauf haben
wird, wie Kriege gekämpft werden.
Nicht nur Kriege, auch Terroranschläge.
Vor allem, wenn du halt Unmengen davon hast. Und das ist ja das,
womit sich jetzt alle die ganze Zeit auseinandersetzen.
Wie schützen wir die Regierungsgebäude, Militärbasen und so weiter vor,
jemand gibt 100.000 Euro für Drohnen aus und lässt die alle reinfliegen.
Das ist sehr, sehr ärgerlich, weil du dich gegen in dem Fall,
was wären das dann, wahrscheinlich 300.000 Drohnen?
Oder 30.000 Euro, was auch immer, gibt es halt einfach gar keine Gegenwehr mehr.
Und das macht mir, das scheint, so nehme ich das gerade wahr.
Und solange dieses Ungleichgewicht herrscht, wird das natürlich weitergehen
mit diesen Drohnen und einfach sehr viel mehr. Die werden damit ja machen, was sie können.
Und das bedeutet, das wird dringend notwendig, dass diese Drohnenabwehrsysteme,
so gut sind und so viel und so billig, dass das aufhört.
Oder dass es in ein Gleichgewicht wiederkommt.
Klar, ich meine, das hast du natürlich immer bei der Militärtechnik.
Militärtechnik ist immer das Wiederherstellen eines Gleichgewichts in dem Moment,
wo du auf der Gegenseite einen technologischen Fortschritt hast,
egal ob das jetzt durch Unterdrückung des elektromagnetischen Spektrums ist
oder eben durch schneller fliegende Drohnensysteme,
neue Sprengmechanismen oder satellitengestützte Systeme oder eben jetzt auch KI im Anflug.
Musst du das entsprechend kontern.
In der Ukraine gibt es jetzt halt diesen neuen Typ von Drohnen,
den die Ukraine gerade massiv ausbaut und auch große Fortschritte macht,
die sogenannten Interceptor-Drohnen, also die halt explizit dafür gedacht sind,
jederzeit on demand zu starten.
Das muss man sich so vorstellen wie so kleine senkrecht startende Raketen,
die extrem aerodynamisch sind und die super hohe Geschwindigkeiten erreichen können.
Also 300 Stundenkilometer und teilweise auch schneller.
Gibt es jetzt auch gerade so einen offenen Wettbewerb, wer immer wieder schnellere macht.
Ich glaube, es gibt jetzt schon welche, die 500, 600 Stundenkilometer schnell fliegen können.
Irre, ja, also wirklich auf Basis von Quadrocoptern.
Aber dann halt Systeme, die selber noch einen Sprengsatz haben und die vor allem
daraufhin optimiert sind, mehr oder weniger automatisch oder zumindest halbautomatisch
auch entsprechende Targets zu entdecken.
Also klassisches Problem in der Ukraine sind diese sogenannten Schahed-Drohnen.
Ursprünglich iranischer Bauart, die Russen bauen das ja mittlerweile selber.
Das sind so lange wie ein Kleinwagen, solche Dinger mit einem normalen Mopedmotor.
Mittlerweile gibt es auch schon Jet-Varianten, die schneller und höher fliegen,
die relativ günstig zu bauen waren im Vergleich zu Cruise Missiles,
die halt einfach da entlang knattern und in irgendwelche Wohngebäude flogen.
Und diese Interceptor-Drohnen sind halt schnell genug, die jederzeit einzufangen,
sind auch schnell genug, um mittlerweile andere Ziele zu erreichen.
Es gab jetzt auch schon einen erfolgreichen Abschluss von Hubschraubern und
wahrscheinlich auch noch ein paar anderen Systemen.
Und da kommt natürlich jetzt auch viel KI zum Einsatz, um diese automatische
Detektion zu machen. Also diese Scheiddrohnen konntest du zum Beispiel schon
an ihrem Sound erkennen.
Es gab auch schon so KI-gestützte Soundnetworks in der Ukraine.
Also überall hast du so Mikrofone, die das dann leiten und auslösen.
Auch sowas gehört natürlich dazu.
Und diese Interceptor-Drohnen sind, würde ich sagen, jetzt gerade so ein bisschen
der heiße Scheiß und das ist definitiv das, wo jetzt alle auch auf die Ukraine schauen und sagen,
können wir das jetzt bitte auch mal haben, weil natürlich alle das Problem sehen,
dass diese Technologie jetzt hier erforderlich sein wird, um Sicherheit herzustellen.
Weil ich glaube, der nächste Angriff wird kommen, in welcher Form auch immer,
aber das ist einfach offensichtlich, dass wir uns darauf einstellen müssen.
Und das, glaube ich, wird sehr, also das würde ich dann doch extrem beunruhigend,
als extrem beunruhigend einordnen, wenn diese...
Wenn das jetzt weitergeht und wenn man das eben nicht mehr nur in einem Krieg,
also von mir aus setzte die Dinge halt ein, um deine Diktatur zu stabilisieren.
Oder um ein feindliches Land halt echt unangenehm zu machen.
Also andere Länder wurden ja schon vor zehn Jahren und länger von den USA mit
Drohnen irgendwie letztendlich sehr unangenehm gemacht, wo dann die Kinder Angst
vor dem freien Himmel haben und so.
Und jetzt sind diese potenziell sehr viel kleinere Drohnen, die vielleicht auch
sehr viel kleinere Schäden anrichten,
so günstig, dass du sehr, sehr viele davon einsetzen kannst und das Compute,
was die brauchen, in irgendeiner Cloud haben kannst.
Dann macht es auch auf einmal sehr viel mehr Sinn, dass sich die USA anstrengen
und sagen, lass mal zusehen, dass wir ein weltumspannendes Internetsystem haben,
Elon, bau mal eben mit deinem Geld und das,
also diese Dystopien, die sind da echt nicht mehr so weit weg.
Ich meine, wir leben ja gerade in einer. Also ich meine, wir haben jetzt den größten...
Ja, aber next jetzt, weißt du, Dystopie. Noch schlimmer. Da steigen jetzt,
die Release-Cycles gehen jetzt, weißt du?
Ja.
Irgendwie wie Firefox. Eins, zwei, drei und dann auf einmal ist er bei Version 500 oder so.
Ach, genau das richtige Thema kurz vor Weihnachten, oder? So herzerwärmend.
Wünscht ihr euch eine Drohne zu Weihnachten? Also Firefox ist jetzt in Version 146.
Aber die haben irgendwann keine Minor-Releases mehr gemacht.
Ich meine, ich erinnere mich noch gut daran, das muss so auch ungefähr vor zehn
Kongressen gewesen sein, noch
in Berlin, wo so das erste Mal so ein Quadrokopter durch den Saal flog.
Das ist viel länger her.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau. das muss aber so 25,
26 C3 irgendwie 15 Jahre maximal gewesen sein, dass es her ist.
Da flogen schon irgendwelche Parrot-Drohnen vor 10, 15 Jahren.
Ja, das war so vor den Parrot-Drohnen noch.
Wie gesagt, da war das sozusagen so ein tolles Hacker-Tool und guck mal,
was man hier alles so schönes mitmachen kann.
Und das ist natürlich schon eine extrem disruptive Technologie Und damals waren
wir natürlich alle noch beseelt von dem Spaßfaktor, den das hat.
Von unserem fliegenden Arduino.
Naja, aber mittlerweile ist es halt wirklich jetzt die primäre Kriegswaffe geworden.
Also das ist halt auch der Grund, warum sich die Ukraine gegen die Russen halten
kann. Das ist halt nur wegen dieser Drohnentechnologie.
Ja, das ist sehr schön. Also alles gut.
Ich mache mir trotzdem ernsthafte Sorgen darüber, wie diese Technologie in zehn Jahren sich… Ja.
Zu Recht.
Und das lässt sich fast kaum sagen. Ich meine, es gibt natürlich Trends,
die sich jetzt abzeichnen.
Das wird jetzt mit der KI und der Zielnahme immer besser werden.
Es gibt jetzt auch einen starken Druck natürlich auf die Satelliten-Navigationssysteme.
Hier entsprechende Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gegen Jamming und Spoofing zu machen.
Das Thema hatten wir ja auch schon mal.
Man sieht das jetzt auch, also Europa, die Ministerkonferenz der ESA hat jetzt
irgendwie der ESA mehr Geld gegeben als jemals zuvor.
Natürlich sicherlich auch mit dem Hintergedanken,
dass hier die Sicherheitsbasis, also die Technologie für die Sicherheitssysteme
Europas gestärkt werden sollen, weil alle jetzt gecheckt haben, wie wichtig das ist.
Ja und das wird, also was ich,
beobachte und jetzt erstmal nur mal zur Kenntnis nehme ist ähm,
Ich bin ja so alt, ich hätte ja noch zur Bundeswehr gemusst.
Das wäre mir niemals in den Sinn gekommen.
Und das kommt mir auch heute niemals in den Sinn.
Natürlich Zivildienstleistender und natürlich auch Pazifist aber,
es ist ja quasi absehbar, dass eine fundamental pazifistische Position,
die jetzt Deutschland auch bei weitem nicht hat,
einen in eine Situation bringen würde, demnächst von irgendwelchen Scheißdrohnen
komplett durchterrorisiert zu werden und,
dass.
Gleichzeitig der Schritt,
sich gegen diese Technologie zu wenden und sie auch selber dann zu haben,
im Rahmen der Abwehr oder auch der Abschreckung oder auch der Möglichkeiten,
ein anderes Land angreifen zu können, wenn es das macht.
Diese ganzen Schritte werden ja jetzt in den nächsten Jahren gegangen werden.
Das ist dann die Spirale der Wettrüstung und Aufrüstung, die wir über Jahrzehnte
immer wieder gesehen haben.
Die in sehr,
unschöne,
Zeiten, Phasen, Jahrzehnte geführt hat.
Ja, man kann natürlich auch sagen, dieses Gleichgewicht oder vielleicht auch
Ungleichgewicht hat natürlich auch dazu geführt, dass es eben genau zu diesen
Kriegssituationen nicht kam.
Kann man jetzt natürlich lange
darüber lamentieren, was jetzt im Einzelnen immer so die Gründe waren,
aber ich glaube, dass allein durch so eine plakative Friedensliebe werden Kriege
nicht verhindert, sondern die Akteure,
die bereit sind, in den Krieg zu ziehen,
lassen sich halt nur mal nur durch Stärke davon abbringen.
Krieg ist Frieden.
Und deswegen ist es leider erforderlich, diese Parität herzustellen und wir
sind halt jetzt gerade in einer Situation,
wo die Akteure sehr viel breiter sind, in diesen Krieg zu ziehen. Das sehen wir ja gerade.
Und dementsprechend muss hier gegengehalten werden, weil wenn das nicht stattfindet,
dann werden wir halt genauso angegriffen werden, wie es jetzt in der Ukraine
auch stattgefunden hat.
Das mag uns unvorstellbar,
vorkommen. Aber ich glaube, es kam uns auch schon unvorstellbar vor,
dass das so passiert in der Ukraine, wie es passiert ist.
Und da verschieben sich natürlich die Realitäten.
Und da stellt sich natürlich auch so die Frage, okay, wenn man jetzt in Technologie ist,
Hackerethik, wie steht man dazu?
Was kann mein Beitrag an der Stelle sein? Und das wird sicherlich noch eine
ganze Menge Leute in Gewissenskonflikte bringen.
Ja, damit dann guten Rutsch.
Frohes Weihnachten.
Ja, naja, das sind natürlich so Gedanken, die einem durch den Kopf gehen und
die glaube ich auch alle in irgendeiner Form beschäftigen.
Und manche mögen sich vielleicht mit dem Gedanken nicht beschäftigen wollen,
andere leiden wahrscheinlich auch genauso unter dieser Situation,
kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Also ich fliege zum Beispiel keine Drohnen mehr.
Also es ist tatsächlich genau diese FPV-Drohnen. Also auch wenn du die Bilder
siehst, die Software, die da drauf läuft, das ist das, was ich halt auf meinen
Kurzflugdrohnen betrieben habe.
Und das hat mir schon so ein bisschen den Spaß an dem Hobby genommen.
Gleichzeitig geht damit natürlich,
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ein unglaublicher Kampfpilot verloren,
weil wenn ich eins mit den Dingern konnte, dann war es irgendwo gegenfliegen Na toll,
Nichts vor mir sicher Super,
Ja, wir sehen uns, einige von euch vielleicht auf dem Kongress?
Jeder nur drei Drohnen.
Oh Gott.
Und,
mal schauen, ob das dann die letzte Sendung dieses Jahr war oder noch eine kommt.
Ja, sag auch mal was hier. Frohe Weihnachten oder so. Da willst du noch irgendwie...
Ich genieße gerade deine Verzweiflung dieses Thema in eine würdige Verabschiedung.
Nee, würdige Verabschiedung. Wenn wir Glück haben, wird das Ding früh genug
an Claudius übergeben und jeder kriegt zwei, drei Drohnen und das Thema ist durch.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich noch der beste der beste der beste Ausgang.
Okay. Okay, Leute, ich entlasse jetzt mal Linus hier aus seinem Schmerz.
Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche und ja, wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.